we've been on the Jerry Springer Show is
in its 24th year and I just signed on to
do four more so we'll go at least 28 and
then I'll see your joining I guess there
was also Maury Povich also being renewed
what is their interest in the in
programming that that you're able to
produce why do you think it's so
attractive well I think we live in a
free and open society and the media
should and in fact now does reflect the
entire population when you and I were
younger television used to only
represent upper middle class white
people and then starting in the 90s and
and I think if our show is made up dent
it's because it's the first time really
on a regular basis we saw people that
aren't of that demographic and it's not
that we didn't know people like that
exist we know not everyone is like the
friends but we'd never seen on
television before
so this was the first time we saw on a
regular basis people on television that
were different that didn't speak the
King's English you know that perhaps
didn't luck out in the gene pool of
parents that you and I have but they're
just like us we're just not used to
seeing them on television but they
really are just like us that's what I've
learned in 24 years doing this show you
know you could take the most successful
person ever in America let's say now
let's say it's Bill Gates just to pick
out a name if Bill Gates had been born
in Ethiopia he'd been dead by the age of
five so this notion that I made it why
can't they is such a fallacy 99% of what
we are we had nothing to do with there's
not one person that had anything to do
with the decision to be born to whom
you'd be born with what kind of brain
what kind of health in what era in what
country what environment you had nothing
to do with that and that more than
anything else is what's giving you the
opportunity to have the life you have so
when we see people that aren't doing so
well or don't speak as well as we do or
you
the f-word and all that kind of stuff
they're not less than us they want to be
happy just like we do and yet there is
this kind of elitism where if you dress
in a suit and you have a title you have
the corner office by god you're better
than that
you know they even call the people on my
toes Joe sometimes they call them trash
you imagine calling another human being
trash Hitler was trash human beings
aren't trash they're less fortunate and
and I think we had that realization that
whoa how lucky am I
you know we'd be much more compassionate
as a society much more caring much less
divided you were the 56 mayor the of the
city I didn't know that I know I was
mayor I didn't know it was number 50
well okay you're number 56 we cannot I
said that's great and do you miss being
a politician being mayor Cincinnati was
the best job I ever had by far that was
my favorite job of all time and if I
could be a mayor for life that's what I
would want to be but you know you can't
because term limits and all of that but
I always kind of knew that politics is
my passion it's almost like part of my
religion it's something I really believe
in and I always knew I would make my
living doing something else because I
didn't want to compromise my politics
with the necessity of winning the next
election because I have to put food on
the table for my family so if I can keep
those two things separate in other words
I make my living being in show business
but on my own time or time that I put
aside every week I just do political
stuff raise money give speeches you know
I'm a die-hard liberal and would you
like to hold elected office again I'm 70
now so I and I don't need to be in
office it's not like oh my gosh what's
gonna happen to America if I'm not in
office so it's not that but I do believe
as a citizen no matter what my job is on
the outside when I'm driving a truck or
working in school or doing a crazy talk
show my responsibility as a citizen is
to be politically active and so that's
just something that was ingrained in me
as a child and
being a child and I got a remark that in
looking up your biography you were born
in a London tube station yeah in a
Highgate tube station yes that come it's
not even a little plaque there say well
because I was born during the war and
women in their night it wasn't so
strange because women in their ninth
month living in London spent their
evenings spent their nights in subway
tunnels subway stations because those
were the bomb shelters and I was born at
11:45 at night I live my first five
years in in England in Hampstead London
and then when I found out I couldn't be
king we came to America yeah so how many
Jerry Springer's are there now you've
got talk shows you've got dramatic roles
that you've fulfilled on TV in film you
are the subject of an opera make my
mother proud okay Gerald you got culture
you're an opera who's the Jerry Springer
today how many of them are there all
going at once
no there there's only one but unlike
virtually everybody else you know when
I'm on a crazy talk show I be I talk
differently than I do when I'm giving a
political speech because the subject
matter is different so I'm just one
person with lots of interests